when moon Ava
umas was just 14 years old she was
forced to become a child bride it should
have been her sister but when the groom
suspected her of no longer being a
virgin he took her back to her family
and insisted on marrying young moon Ava
instead sadly she's interested in the
first night in the bedroom
I kept thinking what if the same thing
happens to me as to my sister I couldn't
move
they told me I would get used to it -
what happened to me but how could I ever
get used to that there's one little bit
older
she comes from the city of Vaughn on the
Turkish Iraqi border among the poorest
regions in Turkey almost one in two
girls are married before they turn 18 a
third don't meet their future husbands
until the wedding
in instances where the girls age
prevents a civil marriage it is
generally possible to find a cleric
willing to perform the ceremony although
theoretically it could land them in
prison for six months the chief cleric
of on the mufti denies marrying off any
children but he also says age is not
that relevant mississauga dead children
in colder parts of the world don't
develop as quickly as those in warmer
regions
if there is any doubt we asked for a
medical certificate which tells us
whether a girl is mature enough to marry
the MSMC have mice most visitors to this
mother and child day care center in van
were child brides they come here to get
advice from social workers and doctors
in the education of their own children
workers here are keen to prevent history
repeating itself because Machoke beliefs
is that when they marry young they're
minors and they're frightened after the
wedding they think their lives belong to
their husbands and they don't dare to
take a single step without them but with
a little explanation and education they
discover their individuality and
understand that they have rights and
then they're willing to protect their
own girls from men yippy the open letter
it took a long time for Minerva to find
some kind of liberation she went back to
school and is now raising three children
on her own the man she was married to is
still her husband but now lives in
western Turkey she now works with an
organization that speaks out against
forced marriage it gives her hope to see
the issue discussed publicly I've done
miss miss old there's a television
series called little bride about a girl
who is married at the same age and in
the same way I was it always reminds me
of what happened to me
bleh but the TV show airs on a private
Turkish Channel during primetime on
Sundays the story revolves around
thirteen year old Zahra who is torn from
her childhood and forced to marry an
older man so far it's been on for 30
episodes the protagonist is played by an
11-year old school girl from Istanbul
who had no prior awareness that there
are places in Turkey where girls her age
are forced to marry her real life and
screen life are worlds apart
saerom lats and is the most difficult
thing so far was sarah's marriage it was
not easy to act that and i felt really
uncomfortable
pretty much everyone finds it bad when
girls marry so early
hopefully the series will help put a
stop to it like is that what we're dicas
artists of the 70 or so series currently
being screened on Turkish television
little bride is the fifth most watched
in the latest episode the child brides
in-laws are summoned by the police but
they claim the child is much older than
she really is in the real world many
adults forge their daughter's birth
certificates in order to be able to
marry them off more quickly
it is such realities that women's
organizations are working to highlight
when an exhibition about minors forced
into marriage is staged in Van it is a
magnet for teachers and their pupils the
girls know what it's all about
it'd be odd color Sheila when a girl of
my age is seen with a boy she sometimes
taken out of school and married off but
my family's not like that they want me
to finish school
Manabu no rasca so losing signal munafa
umas is also at the exhibition her own
marriage was a nightmare but in this
deeply religious region remarrying even
for love is not allowed because a child
bride remains a child bride for life